cours de sciences sociales cinquième
année aujourd'hui la socialisation comme
références bibliographiques à cette
vidéo
michel castres à la socialisation dans
les 100 mots de la sociologie sous la
direction de serge paugam petite mise en
situation pour installer le concept
prenons le cas d'elisabeth qu'à 34 ans
qui est célibataire pas d'enfant et qui
est manager d'une agence de voyages elle
sait qu'elle doit s'habiller pour sortir
en ruelle considère que les poils sont
sales et peu esthétique elle considère
également que la violence est quelque
chose de négatif et pense que les jeunes
sont de moins en moins courageux et
travailleur on pourrait se demander mais
d'où lui viennent ses différentes idées
ses différents types de comportement en
fait tout est acquis par les processus
de socialisation la socialisation
désigne les mécanismes de transmission
de la culture au sens large
ainsi que la manière dont les individus
reçoivent cette transmission et
intériorise des valeurs les normes et
les rôles qui régissent le
fonctionnement de la vie sociale les
valeurs ce sont les grands principes
auxquels chacun croit les normes
ce sont des règles de conduite qui
découlent de ces valeurs et les roule
c'est l'ensemble des normes qui sont
liées à une position où un statut dans
l'espace social autrement dit si on
considère que la violence est quelque
chose de négatif
les normes qui en découleront seront de
ne pas frapper ses condisciples ou son
conjoint par exemple et au niveau des
rôles on attendra que un boxeur lui
puisse faire usage de la violence et que
par exemple un professeur n'en passe pas
usage en tout cas dans sa classe
la socialisation manifeste peut être
assimilée un processus volontaire et
explicite visant à structurer la
personnalité d'autrui la socialisation
la tante correspond quant à elle
davantage un processus où l'enfant
intériorise les normes et les valeurs de
société dans laquelle il vit sans en
avoir conscience
sans qu'il y ait un apprentissage
spécifique ou vraiment l'idée que l'on
participe à ce processus d'apprentissage
la socialisation doit être considéré
comme un processus continu qui concerne
les individus tout au long de leur vie
on distingue classiquement une
socialisation primaire et une
socialisation secondaire la
socialisation primaire correspond à la
période de l'enfance ce processus
s'effectue d'abord dans la famille qui
en constitue la instance principal son
action est essentiel pour la
structuration de l'identité sociale des
individus l'école représente une autre
instance majeure de socialisation
primaire
l'enfant se socialise également de
manière plus formelle à travers le
groupe de pairs autrement dit avec ses
petits camarades de classe
la socialisation secondaire se fonde sur
les acquis de la socialisation primaire
les prolonge éventuellement les
transports elle permet aux adultes de
s'intégrer à des groupes spécifiques ou
le travail d'associations aux partis
politiques qui forment chacun à un
groupe de socialisation nouveau un agent
de socialisation nouveau chaque individu
est ainsi socialiser différents rôles
sociaux et aux statuts qui seront les
siens au cours de sa vie voici un
diagramme qui permet de visualiser les
différents agents de socialisation c'est
à dire les instances qui permettent à la
socialisation de s'effectuer
attention il ne faut pas croire que
chacun de ces agents est conscient de la
socialisation qui le perd certains le
sont comme l'école où la famille
d'autres sont plus diffus comme
le groupe de pairs ou les médias on
distingue pour la socialisation primaire
principalement la famille l'école le
groupe de pairs ou les groupes de pairs
et les médias et pour la socialisation
secondaire les agents sont le monde
professionnel toujours le couple père et
la famille un sens plus réduit notamment
au sein du couple
évidemment la socialisation n'est pas la
main d'une personne à l'autre
elle va dépendre tout d'abord de notre
sexe ou en sciences sociales qu'on en
parle à notre genre et les filles seront
bien sûr socialiser d'une façon
différente des garçons ce qui fait qu'un
saint amand on aura des rôles différents
dans une même société
les garçons s'occuperont peut être de
tout ce qui est bricolage et les filles
seront plus orienté vers la cuisine et
le ménage
bien sûr ce sont des choses construites
sont pas des choses naturelles
c'est la socialisation qui nous inculque
ses différents rôles mais la
socialisation va être également
différent d'une personne à l'autre en
fonction notre origine c'est à dire
d'autre origine culturelle mais aussi
via notre milieu social un enfant d'un
milieu défavorisé ne sera pas évidemment
socialiser de la même manière qu'un
enfant d'une famille bourgeoise bien les
traits et du king voici un texte qui va
nous permettre d'appliquer ces
différents éléments liés ces différents
attributs liés au concept de
socialisation fait pose pour le lire et
une fois que vous l'avez lu il y à un
questionnaire google qui vous est
proposé sur la page facebook du coup je
vous souhaite un bon travail et à très
bientôt